all right so where i left off in the
last presentation i was i was dropping a
penny from from the top of a building uh
what's which once again you should not
do because you can kill somebody
so let's say let's say i'm here here's
the building
here's the building
here's the bad person who's going to
drop something
and let's say they just hold it out and
and it just drops the penny drops
so the penny is going to accelerate at
the rate of gravity so it's going to
accelerate downwards at 10 meters per
second squared so let's let's start with
with an interesting question after
after two seconds so when t equals so
and let's say you know they drop it
right at t equals zero right so after
two seconds
after two seconds
how fast is it going
so time is equal to two seconds or we
could even say it as change in time but
we're assuming that we're starting at
time equals zero so time and change in
time is the same thing
if time is equal to two seconds how fast
is it going to be going
well after two seconds
well let's use that formula velocity
is equal to acceleration well
acceleration is the acceleration of
gravity so that's 10 meters per second
squared
velocity will be 10
meters
per second squared
times time times 2 seconds
times 2
seconds
2 seconds
well we can just
velocity we can multiply the numbers you
get 20.
and then just like the numbers you can
you can treat the the units almost like
variables the seconds is the same thing
as this s right so this s is going to be
in the numerator and you have an s
squared in the denominator so one so the
s
at least this s will cancel out with one
of the the two s's that are multiplied
down here right okay so we'll end up
with well actually let me write it down
it'll be 10 meters
meter seconds per second squared right
and that's the same thing as 20. that
cancels out and this makes that one
right so that equals 20 meters per
second so hopefully you're starting to
get a little intuition why accelerations
units are meters per second squared so
after two seconds we're going 20 meters
per second
now let me ask you a slightly more
difficult problem that might have not
been obvious to you
after two seconds how far has the penny
gone
well this is this is interesting so
we have this formula here distance is
equal to velocity times time
right
but the velocity is changing the entire
time we know after two seconds the
velocity is is is 20 meters per second
right so we could call this the final
velocity so just call that v sub f
that's just a fancy way of saying final
velocity
but right when we start at t equals zero
what was what was the velocity well
right when it started the initial
velocity
v sub i for initial
is equal to 0
meters
per second
right
so what
could can we use this formula
well you might think of a way to already
do it well since the acceleration is
constant
and you can only do this when the
acceleration is constant and in most of
what you'll encounter in a first year
physics course acceleration will be
constant and especially when you're
dealing with gravity the acceleration
will be constant
you can actually take the average
velocity to figure out the distance
right
so what was the average velocity over
the two seconds
well
my final velocity was 20 meters per
second
and my initial velocity was zero meters
per second and obviously i went kind of
continuously over that over those two
seconds from 0 to 20. so my average
velocity let's call that
actually i've never seen it done this
way before but let's just call it
average velocity is equal to the v the
final velocity plus the initial velocity
divided by 2. i just took the average of
the initial and the final
which is
20 plus 0
which is 20
divided by 2 which is equal to
10
meters per second so when i
just
right when i let go of the of of the
rock or the ball or the penny whatever
i'm dropping the thing is stationary so
it's zero meters per second after two
seconds we used this acceleration
formula after two seconds it accelerated
to 20 meters per second
and over the course of those two seconds
its average velocity was 10 meters per
second
so we can now use that average velocity
in this this formula right here
so the average velocity
distance equals average velocity times
time you can kind of make a mental
footnote it's average velocity times
time when the velocity is changing and
acceleration is constant which is most
of what you'll see and in most
projectile motion problems so now we
could say distance
is equal to the average velocity times
time
which equals
10
meters per second
times two seconds
once again the s's cancel out so we're
20 meters
so after two seconds not only is my
velocity 20 meters per second down right
once again if i set speed it would just
be 20 meters per second but velocity is
20 meters per second down
but my distance is the ball or the rock
whatever assuming no air resistance has
dropped 20 meters
so let's see if we can if we can use
that
and and hopefully that that's that makes
a little bit of intuition uh for you
and if you are taking physics which
which you don't have to to view these
videos that's the idea i want to show
you that this is actually
exactly like uh one of the formulas that
you you'll see in your physics class and
it's kind of a shame people tend to just
memorize it in physics without
in their in their you know their
learning projectile motion without
really
without really uh appreciating that it
just comes from distance is equal to
velocity times time
and velocity
is equal to and actually let me let you
know before i said velocity is equal to
acceleration times time let me just
expand that a little bit because i
assume that my initial velocity is zero
let me just say that the final velocity
is equal to the initial velocity right
because you could already be going i
don't know 10 meters per second and then
you're going to accelerate
so the final velocity is equal to the
initial velocity this is an i
plus acceleration
times time
right and we said that the distance
and we could we could rewrite this as
the distance is equal to the average
velocity
times time
then this i just realized how funny that
character looks this is an i
this is an i
so the final velocity is equal to the
initial velocity plus acceleration times
time and the distance is equal to the
average velocity
times time so let's see if we can use
these two formulas which we essentially
just applied in the previous example we
didn't do it exactly so formally to to
come up with with a
a formula for distance
given acceleration and time
well we know that
the average velocity let me go here
oh i switched colors the average
velocity is equal to
the final velocity plus the initial
velocity
divided by two right
well
what
what is the final velocity
well the final velocity is equal to this
so we'll just substitute
so we have the initial velocity
plus acceleration
times time
plus the initial velocity
my eyes are getting blurred
they're not showing off these are all
eyes for initial velocity it looks like
a 2 but i'm i think you get the idea
that's all initial velocity all of that
over 2.
so the average velocity is equal to the
initial velocity plus acceleration times
time plus the initial velocity
all of that divided by 2 well that just
equals
2
times the initial velocity
that looks like an i now
plus acceleration times time
divided by 2
and that equals the initial velocity
plus
acceleration times time
divided by 2. and this might be
intuitive for you as well that the
average velocity
is equal to your initial velocity plus
this is essentially the
the difference between the um
how much you're accelerating over that
time and speed but it's going to be that
divided by 2 because we're taking the
average if what i just said confuse you
don't worry about it you could just
backtrack into what we were saying
before and you think about a lot of
these stuff a lot of these formulas
yourself and and and plug in numbers and
i think it'll start to make more sense
so we figured out that the average
velocity is equal to the initial
velocity plus acceleration times time so
we can just substitute that back into
this original equation
and once again i realized i'm running
out of time so i'll see you shortly